oK we've got to get to this lightning
round I bet we can do it in like two
minutes really okay here are the
dichotomy is just the first thing that
comes to your mind with the superhuman
Shapiro's speed favorite novel so I'll
go with I have like four or five of them
actually so moat Moby Dick is my
favorite if I have to pick one take to a
desert island it's Moby Dick around best
American novel then they're a bunch of
nobody's ever heard of there's one
called every man dies alone which is a
terrific book about a couple who are
living in Nazi Germany
and they decide to basically put out
leaflets their son has been killed in
the war the Germans there something's
been killed in the war as a brown shirt
and they have decided to put out
leaflets resisting Hitler knowing it's
not really gonna do any good about their
relationship it's a terrific book by a
guy named Hans falada who was writing at
the time in Germany so that that's a
really good book there's a little
another little known book that's really
enjoyable just a fun book it's called
the secret of Santa Vittorio by Robert
Crichton they made a movie out of it
that yeah I don't think is particularly
good but the book itself is a really
great read and then of course you have
to add some of the Russians write good
crime and punishment Anna Karenina
but yeah though those would be atop the
list alright favorite philosopher so I
would say either contour lock which is a
real dichotomy gets yeah you're gonna
smash them both together and try to make
sense of that I suppose but but it's
hard it's hard to root against tadka
it's pretty fun spectacular although
reading Conte is brutal just read a
summary of Conte you'll be better off it
is awful it took me so long and so much
masochism to get through the critique of
pure reason it's in you could literally
just have somebody summarize it for you
and get as much out of it as try and
slide your way through 800 pages of
badly translated your favorite color uh
yellow Athens or Jerusalem I mean that's
that both I mean Lepanto or tours
neither LA or DC la la la Ponte la
Batman or Superman oh that's hard that's
the hardest one you've given me versus
Superman if Batman killed people Batman
[Laughter]
perfect favorite musical the one that's
closest to my heart is 1776 the one
that's the most brilliant to Sweeney
Todd favorite movie again I would have
to go like top 10 but the Lord of the
Rings trilogy is fantastic the Dark
Knight trilogy is fantastic there's a
man for all seasons used to be my
favorite for a long time the what's the
name of the film now they made a remake
all the king's men with the original
with Broderick Crawford was up there on
my list
Truman shows a great movie I have a list
of I'll have to do my own list of top
hundred movies I've seen every
oscar-nominated film since 1933
so of course you personally all of them
anyway yeah spirit animal spirit animal
God my spirit animals Ben Shapiro
actually what is your what has been
Shapiro spirit animal I don't even like
animals
edmund spenser well Richard Spencer
anyone who's not Richard yeah among whom
is edmund spenser a good poet democracy
or meritocracy meritocracy meritocracy
or monarchy meritocracy Yale or Harvard
I went to Harvard Law School did Yale or
extreme Yale oh that's pretty good I
thought I was gonna have to go down like
ten of those before I get yeah I'll take
it my country right or wrong my country
when it's right my country when it's
right regular coke or Diet Coke of
regular coke Edmund Burke or Thomas
Paine you have to pick one
Edmund Burke greatest composer Beethoven
favorite book of the Bible that's
another hard one yeah
although our Canon is a lot smaller than
yours it's I do have a particular love
for Samuel one and to the all the David
and install stuff is fantastic
note to self read Samuel one and two uh
Lord of the Rings
we're Game of Thrones uh Lord of the
Rings a hot dog is a sandwich a hot dog
is not a saint a hot dog is not a
sandwich you have to have two separate
pieces of bread to make isn't what about
a hoagie a hoagie doesn't have two
separate pieces of bread also not a
sandwich oh my god this is outrageous
okay final question the right to bear
arms the right to arm bears
what does freedom mean to you well I
mean what kind of country would we be if
we couldn't do both that is a great
point everybody
Ben Shapiro Ben thank you for coming on
so I I real pleasure thank you for
everything it's been mediocre it's been
just solidly media edited out Marshall
Ben thank you